Mel Gibson Mel Gibson okay so apparently
Mel Gibson has outdone himself this time
and not in that the Dark Knight outdid
Batman Begins kind of way but more in
that Kramer's got nothing on me kind of
way so if you haven't heard by now Mel
Gibson's ex recorded a phone
conversation of him just flipping out on
her not gonna lie a smart lady but he
was just going off on him he was calling
her all sorts of [ __ ] saying all sorts
of stuff towards black people and
Mexicans it was crazy
and apparently she claims she did not
mean for the tape to go public yeah
[ __ ] turn that guy who filmed the
Paris Hilton thing or all hanging out
somewhere going yes you know it's weird
how those tapes just get out there like
that you know I mean yeah I'm it's just
fun I didn't mean for it to have him as
if there was you know it just happened
like that you know this is it's crazy
they should make a movie cold night no
just admit it you leaked it and when
listening to the recording upon the
racial slurs and women bashing I kind of
got the impression that he was pissed
off at her for being too hot seriously
he's all like you wear tight clothes you
have big titties and I hate it
are you serious dude I'm gonna go ahead
and chalk that one up to jealous
ex-boyfriend [ __ ] because that's
like that Nintendo 64 kid being all like
in tango 65 but it's stupid awesome
graphics and my a with its definitive 3d
Mario game at the 90s take it back but I
mean Mel you went off about the Jews and
then you apologize and it took a while
but then people forgave you and you even
got to make another movie granted not a
good movie but a movie but man it's
probably not gonna happen this time I
mean the people forgave you once but
racial slander again mixed with verbal
abuse and domestic violence towards
women I'm not gonna lie I think you've
tapped the forgiveness well dry know
there's an old proverb I saw that says
people on thin ice should not tap dance
while throwing around racial slurs and
beating women I saw it on a bumper
sticker once think of it this way Mel I
am the whitest person on the face of the
planet I don't think I can even tan I
consider MC Hammer hardcore gangster rap
and I enjoy Miracle Whip on all my
sandwiches and Wonder Bread God rest its
soul
I am your demographic and I think you're
a douchebag so yeah you're pretty much
screwed but I loved you in maverick so I
put the link to Mel Gibson's recent
magnum opus below go ahead and check it
out see what I'm talking about fair
warning though your blood will boil and
you're gonna burn all your Mad Max DVDs
and like I said the link below is like a
two-minute clip of a 20 minute tape
featuring everything from him slandering
black people Mexicans and on to him
admitting he beats his wife I think he's
trying to reach already
since I think he's trying to use all the
slurs that exist what a cracker that's
right I said that we white people we can
say the c-word til Mel Gibson it has
been real and I bid you farewell
[Music]